la colonia española primero y
estadounidense después puerto rico una
pequeña isla del caribe se configura hoy
como un estado libre asociado a los eeuu
donde sus ciudadanos cuentan con la
nacionalidad estadounidense pero salvo
que trasladen su residencia a otro
estado no pueden votar en las elecciones
presidenciales y aunque tienen un
representante en el congreso este carece
también de votos
todas las grandes cuestiones ya sean
políticas económicas o militares quedan
bajo la jurisdicción federal de los eeuu
últimamente se habla mucho de ese
territorio
y es que hace aproximadamente un año el
gobernador de puerto rico alejandro
garcía padilla anunciaba que la isla no
sería capaz de hacer frente a sus
compromisos financieros esto es a
devolver la abultada deuda contraída
tras casi 10 años de depresión puerto
rico- incurría el default
y este año lejos de haber subsanado al
problema entre mayo y julio la isla va a
suspender pagos en un importe cercano a
los 3.000 millones de dólares puerto
rico también conocido como la carencia
del caribe es hoy insolvente su deuda
pública supera los 72 mil millones de
dólares para una población de apenas
tres millones y medio de personas y si
tenemos en cuenta a las empresas
públicas la deuda superaría con creces
el cien por cien del primero
y al arroz con habichuelas por torrico
pero el regalo
gigante se está discutiendo mucho acerca
de cómo solucionar la grave crisis en la
que se encuentra puerto rico high ses en
puerto rico agua rica o por el estado
libre asociado el puerto rico se está
hablando de cambios en el régimen
jurídico político de una posible
declaración de bancarrota e incluso de
un rescate ahora bien la pregunta que
tenemos que hacernos es como hemos
llegado hasta este punto bien hoy en
visual político vamos a mirar hacia
atrás hoy si vamos a mirar por el
retrovisor para tratar de descubrir las
causas que han llevado a puerto rico a
la quiebra así pues qué es lo que ha
ocurrido bien aunque el gran culpable
sin duda es el gobierno puertorriqueño
que ha gastado salvajemente y ha
despreciado la importancia que en el
tejido económico tienen los conceptos de
empresa negocios y en cierto modo
seguridad jurídica hoy vamos a ver cómo
washington tiene una porción de
responsabilidad tan grande que
prácticamente podemos afirmar que los
eeuu han quebrado por torrico y es que
la gran potencia americana ha
bombardeado a esta isla con cinco
políticas de resultados devastadores 5
políticas en materia de impuestos en
materia de comercio de regulaciones
salarios y asistencia social
deuda libre de impuestos
con la supuesta intención de ayudar a la
economía del puerto rico y favorecer que
su gobierno pudiera acceder a los
mercados de capitales al albor de la ley
d'hont
washington fijó una triple exención
municipal estatal y federal sobre los
intereses de la deuda pública del puerto
rico así si cualquier ciudadano
americano compraba deuda pública de
puerto rico- quedaba exento de pagar
impuestos sobre los intereses recibidos
o dicho de otra manera si un ciudadano
americano compraba deuda de una empresa
tenía que pagar impuestos pero si en
cambio se la compraba a los políticos
puertorriqueños no tenía que pagar
absolutamente nada ya os podéis imaginar
que en las condiciones tan atractivas no
fue extraño que se formase en colas para
prestarle el dinero al gobierno de la
isla dinero fácil para comprar votos
esto es que mejor escenario podemos
imaginar para políticos irresponsables
e ingeniería impositiva contra toda
lógica mientras el gobierno federal
alentaba a que el gobierno de puerto
rico se endeudará cada vez más y más se
lo ponía más difícil a la economía
privada así finalmente en 2006 se
suprimió la llamada sección 936 del
código fiscal que incluye importantes
beneficios para aquellas empresas que
invirtiesen en la isla en un modelo que
había tenido mucho éxito y es que los
años precedentes habían conseguido que
el puerto rico- creciese muchísimo y
llegar a convertirse en un incipiente
potencia manufacturera y farmacéutica
bien no es extraño que una vez
terminados los incentivos en el año 2006
dos años antes de la gran crisis
financiera puerto rico- comenzase su
particular caída al abismo
ley bien marina mercante o ley jones tal
vez el punto más controvertido y la ley
más absurda la ley jones aprobada en
1920 y aún hoy en día en vigor prohíbe
que barcos con bandera extranjera puedan
transportar mercancías que entre dos
puertos de los eeuu así siguiendo esta
ley un barco procedente de china cargado
de contenedores no puede detenerse en
puerto rico tiene que continuar hasta
tierra continua mental descargar sus
contenedores los cuales tienen que
volver a ser cargados en otro barco
estado exit con bandera y tripulación
estadounidense lo que evidentemente en
muchísimo más caro y llevados de vuelta
al puerto rico el resultado de todo esto
es que puerto rico tienen los costes de
envío más caro de todos los países del
caribe algo que no sólo dificulta el
comercio sino que encarece también las
exportaciones y reduce el poder
adquisitivo de todos los puertorriqueños
de hecho para hacernos una idea de la
implicación de esta ley ayuda cabe decir
que puerto rico que tiene renta media
aproximadamente la mitad que el estado
de misisipí el más pobre de los eeuu
continental tiene un coste de vida
superior a la media estatal
el salario mínimo y políticas sociales
el salario mínimo un puerto rico es el
salario mínimo federal es decir 7 con 25
dólares la hora lo que ocurre es que
como hemos visto tanto el nivel de
desarrollo como la renta media de puerto
rico es muy inferior a la del resto de
estados de los eeuu con lo que el efecto
distorsionador de esta política es
enorme el salario mínimo fijado que por
cierto es más alto que el que tenemos en
españa equivale al 77% necesario medio
puertorriqueño es decir del salario
medio de todas las profesiones y
trabajos de la isla
lo que ha conducido a que tan sólo una
de cada tres personas en edad de
trabajar lo hagan por cierto cabe decir
que de estas personas una de cada cuatro
lo hacen para la comunicación pública
con lo que podemos llegar a la
conclusión de que menos del 25 por
ciento de la población de puerto rico
trabaja en la economía productiva una
concurrida zona comercial hace dos años
ese es cómo está hoy en día por otra
parte la regulación federal implica
también un nivel anormalmente alto de
prestaciones sociales para lo que son
los parámetros de puerto rico de hecho
hay estudios que demuestran que a muchas
familias les es conveniente recibir
ayudas sociales antes que trabajar en
tanto en cuanto a los ingresos a los que
van a poder acceder son sustancialmente
mayores
todo esto no sólo deriva de una gran
crisis económica sino también un
auténtico éxodo de población sobre todo
de su población más joven y más
preparada hacia los estados unidos
continentales la salida masiva de
puertorriqueños y puertorriqueñas sobre
todo a eeuu es la muestra más elocuente
del fracaso del modelo económico social
del estado libre asociado así desde el
año 2006 cuando comienza la crisis en
puerto rico se inicia un proceso que ha
diezmado considerablemente
fuerza laboral y productiva de la isla y
es que a la postre los puertorriqueños
tienen la ciudadanía estadounidense y
ante una situación de adversidad les
compensa hacer las maletas y mudarse a
los estados unidos continentales 84.000
sólo el pasado año y hoy ya viven más
puertorriqueños en estados unidos
continental que en el mismo puerto rico
bueno espero que os haya gustado este
vídeo y también por supuesto espero
vuestros comentarios para poder abrir
debate un saludo y hasta la próxima
y la temporada merenguera dominicana
replicó
con méxico colombia y venecia